- THERE HE IS.
- HEY, HEY, HEY, WHAT'S UP?
- HEY, MAN.
WHAT UP, MAN?
- HEY, HERE'S THE DEAL.
100%, GRASS-FED JAPANESE
KOBE BEEF, $35 A POUND.
- THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GRILL
THESE LITTLE HOMEYS UP.
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
IS THAT GROUND CHUCK, MAN?
NO OFFENSE, I AIN'T
TRYING TO PARK MY BENTLEY
NEXT TO YOUR TOYOTA,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
- COME ON, MAN.
- OH, YOU JUST PUTTING THEM
RIGHT NEXT
TO THE FROZEN PATTIES.
YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
- HEY, RELAX, MAN.
I'M GONNA COOK THEM GOOD.
- OKAY, YEAH.
- ALL RIGHT, SO HOW'S
TERESA DOING?
- SHE'S GOOD. SHE'S GOOD.
SHE'S SAD SHE COULDN'T BE HERE.
YOU KNOW,
SHE'S GOT A CLOSING TODAY.
YOU WANT TO FLASH-COOK THOSE,
BECAUSE THEY REAL LEAN.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE GRASS-FED.
SO YOU JUST WANT TO PROBABLY
FLIP THEM RIGHT--RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
- HEY, WHO WANTS CHEESE
ON THEIR BURGER?
- NOBODY, NOBODY.
NOBODY WANTS CHEESE.
- ANYBODY WANT
A DOUBLE BURGER?
- NO, NOBODY WANTS
A DOUBLE BURGER.
THAT'S LIKE PUTTING
A DIAMOND RING ON A PIG HOOF.
I'M SORRY, BUT THE GRASS
THAT THESE COWS ATE
COSTS MORE THAN THIS HOUSE.
- ALL RIGHT, NO DOUBLE BURGERS.
- NO DOUBLE BURGERS--
- HEY, WHAT THE HELL?
- YOU MAY AS WELL
JUST POOP ON THAT.
- WHAT?
- YOU JUST KETCHUP-RAPED
MY KOBE BURGER.
THIS WAS A MISTAKE.
THIS--NO, NO.
NO, NO. UH-UH. NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO.
SEE, THIS MEAT
CAME ALL THE WAY OVER HERE
FROM THE PACIFIC OCEAN
BY BOAT,
BECAUSE THE AIR PRESSURE
WOULD RUIN ITS INTEGRITY.
GIVE ME THAT.
YOU ARE NOT WORTHY.
YOU'LL NEVER LEARN.
THIS IS RIDIC--
THIS IS $126--
THIS LITTLE MOTHER--
$126 WORTH OF BEEF.
Y'ALL NOT WORTHY.
- DID HE TAKE MY DOG?